last year a spasm of left-wing outrage
led to plastic straw bans across the
country they were worse than dangerous
they were unfashionable but what about
plastic bags in a recent interview
Alexandria Kazuya Cortez complained that
she gets too many plastic bags and then
has to throw them away I can be upset
that I get ten plastic bags at the
grocery store and then have to toss out
my plastic bags because the recycling
program in the area is tough and that's
okay that's tough clearly we need
aggressive state intervention the state
of Washington just approved a bill that
would ban all single-use plastic bags
statewide Rhode Island is considering
the same thing because they don't have
enough problems to deal with in
Connecticut which is literally failing
that state wants a ten cent bag tax to
fix the budget deficit soon your bundle
of plastic bags under the sink could be
contraband as illegal as fentanyl or a
box of straws author and columnist and
plastic straw dissident mark Stein joins
us tonight any plastic bags under your
sink yeah there are actually I been
pressed by Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
because things that Democrats now they'd
never heard that for example they're a
big thing of bovine flatulence that they
Democrats have never heard of until a
couple of weeks ago now it ranks higher
than the economy or Obama care they feel
the way about a flatulent Holstein
destroying the planet the way they felt
about Reagan having nukes 35 years ago
and that's impressive for her to for her
to do that I mean obviously at a certain
sense this is a boutique issue we will
be arguing about plastic bags at the
time Kim jong-un decides to drop the big
one on Cleveland and we will look
ridiculous but but what's oddly
revealing about this is that I think
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez comes across as
strangely unwove
this soundbite you know I don't I don't
do a lot of grocery shopping I usually
send my undocumented Honda and
manservant that I keep under the stairs
to do it but when I am in the grocery I
know I know enough to know that you're
always Stanley behind some well-meaning
liberal progressive who issues all the
plastic bags and produces some smelly
disgusting permanent bag that she's been
carrying around from price drop at a
price drop for the last four years and
has the food put in that you mean you
mean the NPR tote bag yeah that is that
bad that is I believe it's they it's
either the the Charlie Rose tote bag or
the gas and Keeler tote bag I don't know
which one what it is they've been me too
but no one's me to their tote bags
they're still good for the fundraisers
so you take they take they take out the
NPR tote bag and they have all the
groceries dropped in it and they don't
have to have the plastic bags there's no
reason for this problem she sounds us
out of it as that famous clip of the
first president Bush marveling at the
grocery scanner which which was a which
was misrepresented anyway but in this
case she sounds weirdly on woke where is
Alexandria's Charlie Rose tote bags
that's what we want to know I think she
thinks that Charlie Rose is a tool of
the establishment probably I I bet if
you were to x-ray her thought she would
be very very anti Charlie Rose but
that's a really good point and next time
I see a oh is see it at Whole Foods all
I will encourage her to get the tote bag
Mark Steyn great to see you thanks a lot
Tucker thanks Marv